would you call yourself a feminist
Samantha I
think BOS like that there's a lot of
toxic femininity in the world and
um you know I I have this conversation
with my my little brother all the time
because he's 19 and he's growing up in a
world where a lot of young men are like
they're terrified of women you know
because we are becoming a lot more
independent and you know and I I I I
feel for for the men of the of the
younger Generations because I think it's
a little bit challenging and they they
really they they're not it's not really
easy for them so in that regard it's you
know it's interesting that you say that
because I mean like you you you know you
talk about the traditional sort of
feminine cues and like the toxic version
of feminism but the conversation you
have with your brother with the
difficulty that he deal with like you
say that women are becoming more
independent but I would say that women
are becoming more like men right and
when women become more like men like
oftentimes we'll ask you know women like
well what do you bring to the table and
she'll say well I've got my own house my
own car I have my job my degree and I'm
fun and it's like they basically just
describe a dude right and they've G got
and created a life for themselves where
they've got their job they're working
towards their investment so they have
the passive income with the you know
with the real estate and you know they
don't need no man they don't need a
relationship but if it happens it
happens sort of thing like that like
that's the that's a typical Avatar of
most gals out there that your younger
brother's you know GNA end up dealing
with can I make a point on that real
quick yeah go ahead um a lot of men
these days aren't acting like men like
the guys my age don't you're absolutely
right act like men so why I it's hard
for me to fall into my feminine self and
have that urge to take care of you know
someone who's taken care of me when
they're not taking care of me when it's
not you know what I mean it's not yeah
you're absolutely right the bar has come
up to even because men boys males are
not actually keeping up with that
standard and it's I can't fall into my
feminine I guess traits if I have to
it's a real problem isn't it to keep my
mask on because I'm coming home to a guy
who doesn't want to talk to me doesn't
want to look at me doesn't want to help
with anything isn't making more money
than me is coming home with the same
money as me but doesn't want to do
anything and can't provide anything
special to me so I now have to provide
for myself
right real problem you know so what's
the solution to
that well if men want a woman to be more
feminine then he needs to be more
masculine fense B I'm not saying it's
man as fault but you're saying it starts
with
men if I'm in a if I'm with a man where
I feel like I
can't hang up my you know my boss lady
attitude or whatever
then it's one of those things where it's
like it's it's a give and a take and for
sure I I me personally I commend giving
more than I probably
should so that's why I don't really fall
into the Super feminine role so quickly
right away it's kind of like well what
do you have to bring to the table before
I kind of fall into what I have to bring
to the table but I don't really know
what the solution to that would be I
don't really have a solution I kind of I
wrong way to
approach my Approach it's a wrong it's
your femininity should not be
conditional our masculinity is not
conditional we are expected to be
masculine no matter what there's no man
that goes into a relationship or
romantic interaction with the woman
saying well I need you to be in your or
feminine so I feel comfortable with
being in my masculine men no matter what
have the burden of performance and we
have to be masculine no matter what
so a man who is really worth his salt is
not going to jump through a bunch of
Hoops and have to prove all of these
things he's busy out proving himself in
the world every day he's out busy
fighting far bigger battles and far
bigger stress and so to come home or
have to then go to a woman and then have
to continue to fight and demonstrate
masculinity and be go to war and be more
combative I mean guys are just not going
to be around and stick around for that
kind of stuff I mean you can you're
women going into relationship saying my
femininity is conditional is is a is a
wrong way to go about things it's as if
like you know guys want to wear dresses
on Saturday nights
but it's up to you to make him masculine
right
it's I I don't understand really that
approach where it's it's a guy's job to
always be on whereas coming to coming
into an interaction with your feminine
side prevailing versus guarding that and
gatekeeping that yeah it's a it's a very
difficult conversation and problem to
solve and I don't know that there's any
way to solve it and like a two hour show
or an hour and a half show but it's like
you know you have women who they're
entirely like Kenzie you're how old 23
yeah and you know like your dating
strategy is not going to lean in
completely I want him to chase me a
little bit but there's you know like a
lead horse that I want but I also want
to run a a crane company and get my
degree in this and I can cook but I'm
not necessarily going to do that I'd
rather get some Pillsbury cookies or
some like it's it's flopping back and
forth and I feel like that came across I
came across so wrong because you really
no no no no I'm just sort of like
summing up some of the talking points
that we've had like I'm not trying to
put you in a corner here or anything
like that but I'm just trying to sum up
some of the points so that the so that
we as a conversation and the viewers can
get this but it's like you know and then
how do you turn that off like how do you
turn off what you've been programmed to
be right like you've got some tattoos on
your body too like tattoos tattooing
your body is a very masculine sort of uh
trait you know it's only in recent
history that women have been you know t
in their body right so it's like women
have adopted a lot of these uh
characteristics and traits and decisions
that conventionally men have been
choosing in the past and you're
absolutely right most guys today are
[__] right like they don't know how
to change attire um I see a lot of dudes
walking around with female breast tissue
dopy dopy dope and they think it's
totally fine it's like dude like you're
18 years old why do you look like this
right like get it together right and
then we've got Samantha over here who's
like yeah I'm real happy with what I do
you know I love my job I love I love to
travel I I like acquiring real estate
but you nobody's ever going to get away
from the fact that men and women are
better together than they are generally
apart that's why you know you're on
that's why you're putting yourself out
there you that's why you date that's why
you go on dating apps that's why you you
know uh solicit the attention by posting
photography and you know going out on
these coffee dat or dinner dat or
whatever because you're because you're
entertaining these elements and it's
like we've got a real problem here with
men and women and again we're not going
to fix any of this but but I just want
to highlight it's like we got
Samantha boss girl kind of chick who's
got it together although you know sweet
and kind obviously seems like a nice gal
we got mem you know the single mom who's
more in her feminine that managed to
find a really good guy she got extremely
lucky we got Kenzie you know the single
G here sort of thing who's I think
you're gonna I mean if I were to check
in you in 10 years I bet you'd probably
have that Crane Company um and a whole
lot of stories about bunch of loser guys
that never made the cut I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out